Guten Morgen Linus.
Guten Morgen Tim.
Was bringt uns eigentlich diese Digitalisierung? 1,67 Euro.
Musik Logbuch Netzpolitik Nummer 456 ihr merkt schon es geht aufwärts vom 14.
März 2023.
Ja genau es fröhlingt ein wenig an in Berlin gerade, leicht.
Ich hab schon Krokus habe ich schon gesehen. Bienen, Bienen.
Das sind ja so early adopter sind das ja.
Das sind die ersten immer. Die machen Fooding bevor es cool ist.
Genau das ist so wie Lichtgestaltung Pionier.
Der Krokus sozusagen, der sich immer zuerst reindringen, sagt hier geht doch was.
Der hat doch kein Winter hier.
Scheint doch die Sonne.
Schlechtes Wetter ist nur wenn man das denkt, dass das schlecht ist.
Das ist eine Frage der Kleidung. Guck mal was ich habe.
Alles eine Frage des Krokus.
Seid GroKo-so!
Mehr kann man dazu nicht sagen.
Was kostet ein Krokus? 1,67 Euro.
Das ist ja kein Anreiz. Da kommen wir gleich zu.
Da kommen wir gleich zu.
Wir haben Kommentare zu den Kommentaren, die werden immer mehr zu Freude.
Inzwischen, wir haben teilweise sogar Kommentare, die keines der aktuell zirkulierenden Memes berühren.
Das würden wir gerne abschaffen.
Memes?
Oder? Zumindest eine Primzahlreferenz oder eine, wie heißen die Dinger?
Da sind schon ein paar Sachen dabei.
Ja aber ne, es dürfen keine mehr, keine Kommentare.
Achso keine anderen dürfen mehr, ohne Referenz läuft einfach mal gar nichts.
Ohne Loop Muffe oder Primzahl, die drei Kommentare hier nicht verlesen.
Genau, fangen wir doch an mit Packstut, der schreibt, in den vergangenen Folgen
sind die Begriffe Beutel, Tüte und Sack etwas durcheinander gegangen.
Sie wurden teils gar kombiniert.
Da in der aktuellen Folge ja schon die Frage nach dem Packstoff geklärt wurde,
was ist Jute und warum sind es doch Baumwollbeutel?
Hier einmal die Definition zu den Packmitteln. Ein Beutel ist ein flexibles,
vollflächiges, raumbildendes Packmittel bis 2700 cm² Zuschnitt.
Tüten sind aus einem zuschnittgefertigten dreieckigen Beutel mit Längsnaht.
Von einem Sack spricht man bei einem flexiblen, vollflächigen,
beim Befüllen raumbildenden Packmittel, welches einen Umfang von mindestens
36 Zentimetern aufweist.
Wer hätte gedacht, dass diese Verpackungsthemen mit eurer Podcast mal relevant würden.
Ansonsten besten Dank für eure Arbeit, auch für Interessierte aus der Verpackung,
immer top aufbereitet. Ja, wir bemühen uns die Themen auch richtig einzupacken für euch.
Egal ob jetzt in Beutel, Tüte oder Sack. Aber das mit der Tüte habe nicht verstanden.
Dreieckige Beutel? Tüte?
Ist das dann sozusagen wo man so seine gebrannten Mandeln mitkriegt,
das ist eine Tüte oder was?
Ach, das heißt die Plastiktüte im Supermarkt ist gar keine Tüte,
das ist ein Plastikbeutel.
Viel spinnender finde ich, wenn es keinen Umfang von mindestens 36 Zentimeter hat, ist es kein Sack.
Kann ja nicht herkommen weißt du.
Ja mit den Säcken und so den Beutel das ist wirklich ein Thema.
Nicht dass jetzt einer das überprüft und dann die Kängurus gar keinen Beutel haben.
Aber das ist schon klar wir sind hier in Deutschland da wird sowas klar durchdefiniert.
Ich finde das ist auch wichtig also das ist eine gute Definition da habe ich wirklich was für übrig.
Stell dir mal vor, es käme jetzt irgendwie jeder Sack des Weges daher und definiert
das anders. Das ist doch völlig klar.
Windbeutel sind das doch.
Das ist eine Definitionsfrage. Elmayyachi schreibt, es gab leider nie einen
Opel Omega 1,6 Liter. Der kleinste Omega A hatte 1,8 Liter Hubraum.
Der Omega B ging bei zwei Litern los. Keine dieser Zahlen ist eine Primzahl.
Zwei ist eine Primzahl.
Ja, also man muss schon, also wenn schon, wenn schon kritisiert,
ne? Und das auch noch in den Kommentar fassen, mein Freund.
Mein lieber Freund Elmar.
Dann, dann auch richtig, ne?
Das wird, wird dann später nochmal bestraft. bestraft. Kostet Bier.
Aber offensichtlich gibt es keine Opel Omega 1,6 Liter. Wer hätte es gedacht? Hab ich mich vertan.
Ja. Kadett.
Das kann gut sein, weil das war so damals war das so, Omega war ja so Oberklasse,
also der Versuch einer Oberklasse, so ein bisschen so größeres Fahrzeug und
das wurde nie unter 1,8 Liter verkauft so was.
1,6 Liter das ist ja so, ja das war ja schon so ein, wie soll ich sagen, Kleinwagen.
Am Astra vielleicht.
Wer sich da heute wundert, Motoren hatten damals nicht so viel Power aus dem
selben Hubraum, deswegen war alles noch sehr Hubraum definiert.
Heutzutage spielt das nicht mehr so eine große Rolle, jetzt geht es sowieso
demnächst nur noch um Kilowatt.
Jetzt geht es nur noch um Windungen. Wie viele Windungen da.
Genau, hier geht es ja auch in der Politik geht es ja dann auch meistens um
Windungen, da muss man immer gucken wie sehr sie sich wieder gewinnen um irgendwie
eine sinnvolle Lösung zu vermeiden.
Naja, dann noch zum elektronischen Personalausweis bzw. zur anonymen Altersverifikation schreibt Simon.
Anonyme Altersverifikation ist tatsächlich ein Feature, das der NPA mit E-ID
seit Beginn unterstützt, aber den Leuten glaubhaft zu machen,
dass sie ihren Ausweis an den Leser halten sollen, aber trotzdem anonym bleiben,
halte ich für eine größere Herausforderung.
Das ist genau der richtige Punkt. Ich hab das, also das bezieht sich ja darauf,
dass ich in der letzten Sendung argumentiert habe, du kannst einen Altersnachweis
irgendwie nur an eine Identität binden und dabei habe ich falsch dargestellt,
dass es diese Funktion oder quasi unterstellt, dass es diese Funktion nicht gäbe.
Wo Simon mich jetzt hier korrigiert.
Das geht, aber das glaubt dir halt auch keiner. Das ist das Hype an deinen Ausweis
hin. Wir lesen den jetzt aus.
Wir lesen nicht aus, wer du bist. Wir gucken nur, ob du alt genug bist.
Ich glaube, wenn ich das richtig erinnere, haben die das dann...
Gab's das nicht auch an Zigarettenautomaten irgendwann? Ja. Dass die geguckt haben, dass man 18 ist?
Ich bin mir nicht so sicher, dass das wirklich diese Funktion benutzt wurde.
Sondern ich glaube es wurde einfach nur...
Nee, nee, die haben das mit Geldkarte oder sowas gemacht, ne?
Ich glaube es war sagen wir mal nur so dieses, du hast so ein Dokument,
dann musst du so und so alt mindestens sein.
Jaja, irgendwie so.
So war das glaube ich, ne? Stefan erläutert das auch nochmal ein bisschen genauer.
Der neue Personalausweis kann genau das, Altersprüfung ohne weitere Daten zu
offenbaren und zwar nicht nur für 18, sondern für jedes Alter ohne das Geburtsdatum
zu verraten. Wie das geht?
Erstens, der Service fragt den Ausweis, ob die Person vor dem Tag X geboren wurde.
Zweitens, der Ausweis zeigt diese Frage an und fragt nach der PIN.
Drittens, bei richtiger PIN antwortet der Ausweis ja oder nein.
Also es ist natürlich nicht, dass der Ausweis eine PIN anzeigt,
weil das kann er natürlich nicht, sondern ein entsprechendes Lesegerät.
Beachte a. Um das Geburtsdatum zu ermitteln müsste der Service häufig fragen.
B. Die PIN bindet den Altersnachweis an die Person. c.
Jeder Service kriegt vom Ausweis eine andere zufällige ID zu sehen,
die aus Servicezertifikat und Ausweiszertifikat generiert wird.
Mehrere Services können untereinander die Daten nicht korrelieren.
Bonus die Echtheit der Antwort ist durch den Ablauf des Protokolls garantiert
sie ist aber trotzdem nicht signiert deshalb kann sie nicht weitergegeben oder
weiterverkauft werden.
Super, also es ist erstens mal richtig schön erklärt wie man es macht oder machen
kann aber ich weise kurz darauf hin ja am Ende ist der Anker für diesen Nachweis der Ausweis.
Und dass ich nachweise, dass ich auch die berechtigte Person bin,
in dem hier, in dem von Stefan vorgetragenen Ablauf.
Auch die PIN eingebe. Das heißt, es funktioniert nicht, den Ausweis einer anderen
Person zu nehmen, weil ich im Zweifelsfall die PIN nicht habe.
Jetzt das Ganze also in irgendeiner Form loszulösen davon, dass einmal eine
hoheitliche Stelle dir ausgestellt hat, Das ist ein Dokument mit dem du einen
Altersnachweis gegenüber dritten und nicht gefälscht und so weiter.
Das ist eben auch nur mit einem Ausweis nach meinem Verständnis möglich.
Ja, also irgendeine Blockchain-Lösung oder sonstiges muss immer daran gebunden
sein, dass es noch diesen Nachweis gibt, dass ich auch die Person bin,
der das ausgestellt wurde.
Und dieser Nachweis ist am Ende darin verankert, dass irgendjemand mal festgestellt
hat, dass ich auch wirklich diese Person bin.
Insofern sehe ich nicht die technische Möglichkeit, das Gleiche,
was Stefan jetzt hier zeigt, am Ende ohne Ausweis zu machen.
Und wo man jetzt auch nochmal schauen müsste, Da bin ich etwas unsicher,
weil er hat jetzt den Ablauf geschildert.
Der Ausweis antwortet ja oder nein. Der Ausweis wird von dem Leser,
weiß er auf jeden Fall das abfragende Zertifikat.
Und wahrscheinlich gibt es hier irgendeine Möglichkeit, dass der Service die
zufällige ID von diesem Ausweis kriegt.
Der Service Zertifikat und Ausweis Zertifikat. Okay, also du kriegst eine ID, die zu dir gehört.
Jetzt stellt sich die Frage, wo, an welcher Stelle da jetzt am Ende verhindert wird,
dass wenn dieser Service jetzt sagt,
ich prüfe mal diese Signatur, ne doch, mit der öffentlichen Signatur kann er
die Prüfung vornehmen, ohne dass die andere Stelle tatsächlich weiß,
dass ich es war, also die ausgebende Stelle weiß, dass ich es war.
Aber das ganze Ding ohne Ausweis kann man auch wieder bauen,
es muss aber am Ende an den Ausweis gebunden sein.
Also ich sehe da irgendwie, ehrlich gesagt, keinen sinnvollen Weg nach vorne,
das vollständig von einer Identifikation und damit am Ende dem Ausweis zu lösen.
Ja beziehungsweise so richtig, ich meine das Ding ist, jetzt haben wir so eine,
also was heißt wir, deutsche Staatsbürger haben das, ich verstehe ja immer noch
nicht warum eigentlich ausländische, also Leute die in Deutschland wohnen aber
nicht Deutsche sind, warum die keinen Personalausweis haben.
Hast du schon mal das Feedback bekommen, die Europakarte oder sowas, Deutschland.
Ja genau also okay wenn das genauso funktioniert, also bloß niemand weiß wie
man damit umgeht, niemand versteht warum es eine Ausweis App 2 gibt.
Weil es eine 1 gibt.
Gab.
Ja gut, aber wenn der, wenn Elmar Yatschi sagt es gab ein Omega A und ein Omega
B, dann kannst du doch auch nicht sagen wieso heißt der B jetzt,
B, den A gibt er nicht mehr.
Ja, also kurz gesagt, ich glaube das wird sich alles erst in dem Moment durchsetzen,
wo es aufs Telefon kommt.
Ja, alles richtig.
Aber da haben wir ja auch in der letzten Saison darüber gesprochen,
wenn die ID auf dem Telefon ist, dann machst du damit den Schritt in allgegenwärtige
Identifikation und den Identifikationsvorgang oder auch den Altersnachweisvorgang
in einem gewissen Maß kompliziert zu halten,
trägt eben auch dazu bei, dass er nicht allzu oft angewendet wird.
Ja, aber ich meine leider dann eben auch nicht dann, wenn es mal wirklich angemessen wäre.
Ja, du kannst gerne bei Pornhub mal vorschlagen, dass sie diesen Prozess mit
dir durchlaufen, jedes Mal, wenn du da abends noch ein Filmchen gucken möchtest.
Ja klar, also über die Gefahren müssen wir uns gar nicht groß unterhalten,
aber das ist halt, Chancen und Risiken muss man immer so ein bisschen abwägen
und bei dem beklagenswerten Zustand der Digitalisierung in unseren Breiten,
muss schon jetzt nochmal ein bisschen was passieren und Identity gehört nun
mal leider zu den Enablern schlechthin für Digitalisierung.
Ja aber Tim, ganz kurz, wenn ich dich daran erinnern darf, wir haben über diesen
Kontext gesprochen, im Thema Chat-Kontrolle und Altersnachweis,
um überhaupt irgendwo ein Internet-Chat-Zugang zu bekommen.
Also wir reden ja hier von harten
Einschränkungen und vollumfassendem Altersnachweis und Identifikation.
Ich würde jetzt ungerne in dem Kontext die Diskussion aufmachen,
okay, wie hebt man jetzt ID in eine zeitgemäße, ähm,
...
Auf eine zeitgemäße Ebene, sicherlich nicht indem man da Privatanbieter rein
holt und sicherlich nicht indem man irgendwelche Blockchain Technologien macht
oder was sonst Udo und seine Kollegen sich als nächstes ausdenken.
Vollkommen klar. Das ist eine hoheitliche Geschichte und muss auch genau dort
bleiben und ordentlich gelöst werden. Tatsächlich ist sie technisch bereits
ansatzweise richtig gelöst. Die Basis dafür ist da. Es ist bloß noch keinem
gelungen das letzte Glied in der Kette zu schließen.
Sodass es auch jeder nutzen kann.
Und das ist glaube ich die Falle,
in der wir uns gerade befinden, dass wir nämlich eine Technologie vor vielen
Jahren hier eingeführt haben mit dem NPA, dem neuen Personalausweis,
der ja nicht mehr EPA heißt, weil der die elektronische Patientenakte, mit dem NPA.
Wo wir feststellen, junge, junge, da haben sich Leute vor 10,
15 Jahren echt schon mal Gedanken gemacht, wie man sowas alles ordentlich löst.
Ungünstigerweise, ja damals noch nicht absehbar, der Siegeszug des Smartphones, ja, in diesem Ausmaß.
Aber zumindest können wir sagen, ja pass auf, diese bestimmte Lösung,
die ihr versucht von hinten durch die Brust ins Auge zu bauen, die gibt es schon.
Das ist durchaus technisch möglich und deswegen finde ich die Hinweise hier
von Stefan und Simon auch so wichtig zu sagen, ein paar Dinge sind auch schon
gelöst, muss man vielleicht gar nicht neu erfinden.
Was auch schon gelöst ist, ist die Frage, was denn die beste Primzahl ist.
Sicherlich eine Frage, die euch jetzt seit mehreren Folgen schon einfach Tag und Nacht beschäftigt.
Dazu äußert sich Daniel und berichtet, Sheldon aus Big Bang Theory hat mal erklärt,
was die beste Zahl ist, nämlich die 73.
Die 73 ist die 21. Primzahl, ihre Spiegelzahl, die 37, ist die 12.
Primzahl. Deren Spiegelzahl wiederum, die 21, ist das Produkt von 7 und 3.
Es konnte sogar mathematisch gezeigt werden, dass 73 tatsächlich die einzige
Zahl mit diesen Eigenschaften ist. Die sogenannte Sheldon-Primzahl.
Binär ausgedrückt ist die 73
ein Palindrom, da sie vorwärts wie rückwärts geschrieben 1001001 lautet.
Der Morse-Code, lang, lang, Punkt, Punkt, Punkt, Punkt, Punkt,
Punkt, Strich, Strich, ist ebenfalls symmetrisch.
Nachzusehen natürlich in der 73 folge der Serie.
Es ist wirklich irre was sie bei Big Bang Theory an Nerd Kram unterbringen das
ist wirklich erfreulich.
Da kann dann endlich mal alles berichtet werden was sich Nerds so ausgedacht haben.
Dann gibt es noch einen Hinweis zum Thema Glasfaserkabelreparatur,
gab es tatsächlich mehrere Kommentare, aber wir zitieren mal Smolpp,
der das mal ganz ausführlich berichtet hat, wie denn das eigentlich funktioniert.
Bezüglich eurer Ungereimtheiten bei dem Glasfaserschaden. Schön formuliert, eure Ungereimtheiten.
Man hat nicht gesagt, dass wir scheiße erzählen.
Ja, das hat sich nicht gereimt. Wir sollten mehr darauf achten,
dass sich die Sachen, die wir sagen, reimen.
Ja, wie in dem berühmten Gedicht, Der Schüttelreim, der Schüttelreim,
der reimt sich nicht, der reimt sich nicht.
Also, er schreibt, um den Schaden relativ einfach zu beheben,
wird an der Schadstelle an beiden Enden so weit zurückgegangen,
dass man wieder genug Kabel zum Spleißen hat.
Man braucht in der Regel zwei bis drei Meter.
Dort werden dann Muffen gesetzt und die Fasern eingelegt.
Also für mich ist eine Muffe jetzt etwas, was so quasi so für jede Faser so einen Slot hat, ne?
Dass die sozusagen in so einem geordneten Raum sind. So verstehe ich das.
Nun verbindet man die beiden, oder was ist für dich eine Muffe?
Linus. Ich gucke mal kurz.
Also Muffe ist so ein Wort.
Muffe ist ein Beutel.
Das steckt man auf was anderes drauf. Ja, ne?
Genau, also eine Muffe ist in der Installationstechnik ein Bauelement zur unterbrechungsfreien
Verbindung zweier Rohre oder Kabel und das Gegenstück zum Nippel.
Bewästigungsbauteile mit Innengewinde.
Moment Tim, das ist ja nicht so einfach. Bewästigungsbauteile mit Innengewinde,
die mehr als zweimal so lang wie der Innendurchmesser sind, werden auch als
Gewindemuffen bezeichnet. Untertitel im Auftrag des ZDF für funk, 2017,
Jetzt ist die Frage, gibt es auch Gewinde Nippel oder heißen die dann schon Schraube?
Alles ist Nippel außer der Muffe.
Das ist also eine Muffe. So hätte ich es jetzt auch so.
Okay, also Muffe ist was, was man so rüber steckt.
Ja, ein größeres Rohr um zwei dünnere zu verbinden.
Genau, aber ich hab mich jetzt nur gefragt, was bedeutet das für diese Glasfasern,
wenn die eingelegt werden? Also sind dann sozusagen in dieser Muffe nochmal so Slots?
Egal, ich fahre mal fort.
Nun verbindet man die beiden Muffen noch mit einem neuen Kabel,
spleißt alle Fasern eins zu eins durch.
Fertig. Fertig. Man hat also am Ende zwei Muffen in denen die beiden Kabelenden
des defekten Kabels eingelegt sind. Von Muffe A zum Muffe B wird ein neues Kabel
gelegt und an beiden Muffen werden die Fasern eins zu eins durchgespleißt.
An jeder Muffe sind dann zwei Personen. Einer setzt die Kabel ab und legt die
Fasern ein, der andere spleißt. Eventuell werden noch die wichtigsten Fasern
priorisiert um den Stress zu minimieren.
Und um die Fasern zu identifizieren, gibt es einen Farbcode mit zwölf Farben.
Es sind im Normalfall immer zwölf Fasern zu einem Bündel zusammengefasst.
Sowohl die Bündeladern als auch die Fasern sind farblich markiert.
Falls die zwölf Farben nicht mehr ausreichen sollten, wird mit Strichen weitergearbeitet.
Oder es werden zwölf Bündeladern à zwölf Fasern, also insgesamt 144 Fasern in
einer größeren Ader zusammengefasst.
Bei 576 Fasern wären das also 5 große Adern mit jeweils 12 Bündeladern mit jeweils 12 Fasern.
Ich hoffe das war jetzt nicht zu verwirrend. Liebe Grüße Franz.
Und das kommt dann in einen Beutel.
Oder in den Sack.
Ich habe, glaube ich, auf Wikipedia ein Bild gefunden.
Wo jemand relativ viel zu splicen hat,
wenn ich das so, scheint mir das zu sein, das ist eine Glasfaserkabelmuffe mit
einem Splicegerät daneben.
Und da kann der sich das in der Muffe schön sortieren und dann wird das gespliced.
Ja, das sieht ganz sinnvoll aus. Also man macht die Zuordnung mit Farben.
Jetzt ist halt die Frage, ob der ein Fusionssplice, ein Klebesplice oder ein
Krimsplice oder ein No Epoxy, No Polish mechanischer Splice.
Das erklären wir euch aber beim nächsten Mal.
Irgendwo anders wurde auch noch kommentiert, so meiner wilden Idee,
man löst das alles in Software, dass es sich leider nicht unbedingt immer so
ohne weiteres mit Switches realisieren lässt und teilweise auch einzelne Fasern
dann untervermietet sind,
sodass sie also auch physikalisch irgendwo anders aufschlagen,
sodass man da nicht unbedingt immer elektronisch upmappen kann.
Offensichtlich haben aber hier die Glasfaser Reparateure die Sache voll im Griff mit Farben.
Ist doch wirklich ein farbenfroher Job den die haben.
Ja und die haben schon Fusion.
Kalte Fusion draußen im November im Kramer.
Bin mir nicht so sicher, ob die so kann. Okay, das muss jetzt auch einer da haben.
Ja, das sind da auf jeden Fall.
Merken wir uns.
Lieber nicht mit dem Bagger in die Glasfaser.
Ja.
So, jetzt hat ...
Lauterbach endlich ein anderes Thema.
Pandemie zu Ende, jetzt muss der sich ein neues Thema suchen.
Und er hat jetzt vorgestellt die Digitalstrategie.
Und vielleicht dazu einleitend ein paar kleine Bemerkungen. Also eine Strategie
gibt ja sehr große politische Ziele vor,
die man nicht notwendigerweise dann in konkreten Details münden.
Das heißt, wenn wir heute diskutieren, können wir nur relativ wenig über die
tatsächliche Implementierung und Umsetzung sprechen.
Das wäre dann eher so Taktik und Implementierung, aber eben die große Zielvorgabe
für die Gesundheitspolitik.
Des Weiteren, wenn ich das richtig in Erinnerung halte, ist der Karl Lauterbach ja Epidemiologe.
Vor allem, weil man sich wundert, dass der nicht jetzt in den letzten Jahren
mal eine Fortbildung zum Pandemiologen gemacht hat.
Das ist das Gleiche.
Das große Pandemie-Plom hat er jetzt.
Pandi-Plom sozusagen.
Pandiplomierter Epidemiologe.
Und natürlich kann man jetzt,
wenn ein solcher Mensch jetzt Gesundheitsminister ist und eine Digitalstrategie macht,
dann kann man sich die Gedanken machen,
dass er natürlich, oder kann man sich ausmalen, dass er die Datenbasis verbessern
möchte, unter der seine Wissenschaft natürlich die letzten Jahrhunderte oder Tausende gelitten hat.
Dass es eben viele Daten dezentral irgendwo gibt,
die, stünden sie der Forschung zur Verfügung,
vielleicht sehr viele Studiendesigns vereinfachen würden, sehr viele medizinische
Kenntnisse einfacher herbeiführen würden.
Und das ist jetzt so ein bisschen der Hintergrund oder scheint mir einer der
Schwerpunkte von Karl Lauterbach zu sein.
Und zunächst einmal, wenn man jetzt alles andere aus dem Vorlest,
denke ich, dass da sicherlich ein sehr großer Datenschatz zu heben ist,
weil wir, glaube ich, relativ wenig noch über die Korrelationen,
Risikofaktoren von unterschiedlichen Krankheiten so kennen.
Man weiß, bestimmte Lebensmittel oder Genussmittel führen zu bestimmten Krankheiten.
Aber da gibt es wahrscheinlich noch eine ganze Menge mehr.
Wer sich mit Karl Lauterbach so ein bisschen auseinandersetzt,
weiß ja, dass der Mann mehr oder weniger kein Salz zu sich nimmt,
weil übermäßiger Salzkonsum mit großen Krankheiten verbunden ist und so weiter
und so fort. noch sehr viel mehr.
Wissen zu heben, wenn wir jetzt die Gesundheit verdaten.
Und wenn man sich mal anschaut, wie jetzt einzelne Arztpraxen Datenhaltung betreiben,
dann denke ich, würde ich eingangs
schon mal sagen, das ganz große Problem scheint nämlich dort zu sein.
Also in, wie schaffe ich denn jetzt mal eine Datenvereinheitlichung überhaupt dafür?
Wenn die eine Zahnärztin, was weiß ich, das so festhält und die andere so,
dann kann ich noch so viele Daten an zentraler Stelle sammeln.
Wenn ich kein Datenmodell habe, in dem sich das abbilden lässt,
dann habe ich auch nicht die Erkenntnisse.
Das große Problem der medizinischen Studie oder der medizinischen Meta-Analyse
oder was auch immer ist natürlich wie in jedem anderen Bereich auch,
überhaupt erstmal ein Datenmodell zu finden, was alle relevanten Faktoren,
die du untersuchen möchtest, auch abbildet. Und dieses Problem ist ungewiss.
Also es ist nicht so, dass es keine gibt, ne? Ja, aber es ist auch nicht so,
dass es keine Datenmodelle gibt für Krankheiten und so was.
Ja, ja, richtig, aber du gehst ja genau davon aus, wenn du sagst,
wir wollen hier Dinge untersuchen, von denen wir noch nicht wissen,
dass sie Zusammenhänge haben, dann muss ich ja erst mal irgendwie andere dazu
bringen, dass sie die erfassen.
Also beispielsweise, klar kann ich jetzt von allen Menschen alle Diagnosen in
irgendeine Datenbank packen und da habe ich immer noch keine Korrelationen zu
Risikofaktoren wie Salzkonsum oder so etwas.
Sondern nur Korrelationen zu anderen Krankheiten, die wiederum jetzt nicht allzu
schwer zu erforschen sind.
Also ich will nur sagen, die vollständige oder die große Arbeit,
eine derartige zentrale Datenfassung irgendwie überhaupt einem Gewinn hinzuzuführen,
die würde auf jeden Fall noch vor uns stehen und die geht natürlich auch mit
enormen Ineffizienzen einher.
Wer sich erinnert, ich glaube das hatte Flipke auch bei uns in der Sendung natürlich
dargestellt, als wir über die Konnektoren gesprochen haben, im Moment ist die
EPA mehr oder weniger sowas wie so ein Cloud-Speicher, wo PDFs hochgeladen werden.
Und das ist natürlich nicht das, was irgendwie jetzt die Forschungsideen eines
Epidemiologen auch nur im Entferntesten ermöglicht.
Ja, also das meine ich mit, dass es der ungelöste Teil des Problems ist.
Also eine reale Datenarchitektur, die quasi deutschlandweit oder im Idealfall
natürlich Europa und weltweit definiert ist und in Betrieb genommen werden kann
und die halt die Anforderungen an Security,
an Privatsphäre aber eben auch an Forschung und Nützlichkeit und den Workflow
des Gesundheitssystems das entsprechend alles berücksichtigt und im Idealfall optimal bedient.
Das wäre jetzt so die Idealvorstellung, die wird man nie erreichen.
Die sollte natürlich eine Idealvorstellung sein. Was denn sonst?
Sonst brauchst du ja gar nicht erst auf die Bühne zu kommen.
Die setze ich jetzt ein bisschen niedriger an und sage, naja,
vielleicht haben wir schon mal einen Vorteil,
wenn wir es schaffen, dass ein Mensch seine Diagnosen nicht bei jedem neuen
Kontakt mit einer Ärztin aus dem Gedächtnis zitieren muss.
Ja, also ist, keine Ahnung, kommst zum Beispiel, sagen wir mal der Rettungsdienst kommt, ja?
Du bist bewusstlos geworden, Rettungsdienst kommt, ja? Und der weiß jetzt zum
Beispiel nicht, dass du Diabetikerin bist oder schon den dritten Herzinfarkt
hattest oder solche Dinge, ne? Also die medizinische Vorgeschichte im Notfall.
Kann durchaus natürlich von Interesse sein. Ist immer so ein Beispiel,
was da jetzt auch angeführt wird.
Wo jetzt zum Beispiel auch Apple hat dem ja, glaube ich so, du kannst Medical
Information hinterlegen.
Zum Beispiel sagen hier übrigens ich bin Epileptikerin, ich nehme regelmäßig
Nitro oder sowas, das gibt's glaube ich.
Notfallpass und sowas.
Dann hatten wir ja auch schon mal das Feedback eines Hörers,
der sagt, ja, wenn man jetzt so chronisch krank ist und dann zu vielen unterschiedlichen
Expertinnen gehen muss die ganze Zeit und dann,
boah, kann der Arzt sich nochmal bemühen, dass er jetzt jetzt scheiß Röntgenbild
nochmal der Ärztin schickt von der anderen Praxis und da hat der jetzt keinen
Bock, da kriegt der aber nicht 1,67 Euro für, deswegen macht der das jetzt nicht.
Solche Probleme, die gibt es auf jeden Fall. Alle und da gibt es sicherlich
auch Potenziale, die man optimieren könnte. Oder auch Voruntersuchungen und so weiter.
Impfungen, irgend so ein Kram.
Aber all das würde ja nur funktionieren, wenn diese Daten auch in irgendeinem
sinnvoll strukturierten Format vorliegen. Also wenn ich jetzt sage,
hier ist der Patient, der Tim kippt um und sagt, mir ist ganz schummerig.
Jetzt kommt der Notarzt und sagt, jetzt müssen wir mal gucken,
ja, gucken wir mal die Patientenakte.
Und dann gibt es halt so eine lose Blättersammlung von irgendwelchen Scans,
die irgendwelche Leute zu irgendwelchen Zeitpunkten mal da hochgeladen haben.
Und vielleicht dann noch strukturiert so ein paar ICD-Diagnosen,
wie der Tim über die Zeit gesammelt hat.
Das hilft natürlich auch nicht wirklich jemandem weiter.
Nur um mal so zu sagen, was hier die Aufgabe ist, die man angehen möchte.
Und dass jetzt zu all dem natürlich noch gehören müsste,
dass wir anerkennen, dass es hier um hochprivate Daten handelt,
von höchstem Schutzbedarf und Schutzanspruch, mit unter katastrophalen Konsequenzen,
wenn sie in falsche Hände gelangen.
Das muss man ja einfach mal festhalten.
Und diesen beiden Ansprüchen, ich glaube, den beiden gerecht zu werden,
und da sage ich jetzt spezifisch beiden gerecht zu werden, ist der Anspruch
nicht, die gegeneinander abzuwägen und vielleicht zu sagen, der Datenschutz
tötet uns alle, wir müssen die Daten jetzt alle auf einen Haufen werfen und gucken können.
Das sind ja beides keine, würde man das sagen, verantwortungsbewussten Positionen in diesem Kontext.
Und man könnte hier sicherlich eine sinnvolle Lösung bauen, die überzeugt.
Jetzt können wir uns mal gucken, was kommt denn jetzt aus dem Gesundheitsministerium
für Ideen? Ja, zum Beispiel, wir möchten gerne die EPA für alle ermöglichen.
Okay, als ich letztes Mal geguckt habe, war das bereits der Fall.
Kann ich bekommen. Ist für alle erhältlich bei Bedarf.
Aber deswegen führen sie ein Opt-out Prinzip ein.
Das bedeutet, wenn du nicht aktiv widersprichst, hast du eine EPA.
Gut, kann man jetzt sagen, das war, glaube ich, auch diese Änderung war die,
die dann auch dem Personalausweis irgendwann mal zur Verbreitung verholfen hat.
Weil so ne, was der Bauer nicht kennt, der Fred-Denich-Mentalität sich durchgesetzt hatte.
Kann man, ich weiß gar nicht, ob das so ohne weiteres geht, ne?
Also, ehrlich gesagt, weiß ich wirklich nicht, ob man so einfach bei so krassen
Datenhaltungen jetzt einfach ein Opt-Out-Verfahren machen kann.
Kommt wahrscheinlich darauf an, wie nachher die tatsächliche Nutzung ist.
Dass man sagt, ok, jede versicherte Karte bringt die Funktion jetzt erstmal
mit. Du kannst erstens, du könntest sagen, du willst noch nicht mal die Funktion haben.
Und du kannst aber auch im weiteren Verlauf immer sagen, du möchtest nicht,
dass da irgendwas reingetan wird. Ist vielleicht möglich.
Dann sollen 100% aller Behandlungsfälle im Videokontakt stattfinden dürfen.
Also reine Video-Arztpraxen könnte man jetzt hier offenbar bauen.
Das positive Nutzererlebnis von Telematikinfrastrukturanwendung wird zum Zulassungskriterium.
Damit ist das Ding eigentlich gestorben würde ich sagen. Kannst du das nochmal
sagen? Das positive Nutzererlebnis von TI, also Telematikinfrastrukturanwendung
wird zum Zulassungskriterium.
Also wenn das kein positives Nutzererlebnis ist, dann wird es nicht zugelassen.
Ich würde sagen wir könnten jetzt einpacken.
Ja okay dann fang ich mich, was sind die Kriterien dafür?
Also geht es darum, dass Herr Lautermacher ein positives Nutzererlebnis hat oder ich?
Ich denke mal was sie damit zum Ausdruck bringen wollen ist,
dass es mal erprobt wird, ob man das benutzen kann und wenn die Nutzer sagen,
ist scheiße, dann bietet das ein App Store.
Ja das finde ich ja grundsätzlich schon mal ganz gut, dass man sowas berücksichtigt,
auch wenn es mit den Kriterien dann so eine Sache ist.
Nicht so gut ist, ich erinnere hier an die Sendung mit Flüppke,
sie wollen die Position der Gematik stärken.
Und die Gematik ist ja dieser Wirtschaftsverbands nähere Zusammenschluss,
wo also relevante Teile des Gesundheitswesens sich auch ihre Regeln selber machen können.
Also ein instransparentes Privatunternehmen, das jetzt hier mehr Stärke bekommen
soll bei dieser Entscheidungsfindung.
Das heißt, die Politik gibt hier unnötigerweise die Hoheit aus der Hand.
Verstehe ich nicht unbedingt, warum er das machen wollen würde.
Und dann kommt, was ja natürlich sehr viel besprochen wurde und was hier eine
Entscheidung mit sehr weitreichenden Konsequenzen ist,
die Datensilos werden für die Wissenschaft geöffnet und dann kriegt man die
unter Forschungspseudonym,
das heißt, da steht jetzt nicht dein Name dran, sondern eine ID.
Ja und.
Kurze Anmerkung noch, weil ich glaube so kann man das nicht stehen lassen,
dass die Gematik jetzt allein ein Verbund aus privaten Unternehmen ist.
Das ist so ja nicht richtig.
Hält zu 51 Prozent dem Staat oder wie war das?
Genau das Bundesministerium für Gesundheit hält 51 Prozent der Geschäftsanteile,
allerdings die GKV Spitzenverband finanziert das irgendwie zu 100 Prozent. Also.
Klar, irgendjemand muss den ganzen Krempel am Ende spezifizieren und ich würde
mal zustimmen, dass das eine Herausforderung ist, die jetzt idealerweise nicht
im Bundestag bewältigt und auch nicht im Gesundheitsministerium.
Es ist vielleicht nicht unbedingt, also ich würde jetzt nicht generell sagen,
dass diese Struktur, die sie sich mit der Gematik hier gewählt haben,
der falsche Ansatz ist, das heißt nicht automatisch, dass die gute Arbeit leisten
oder immer richtig liegen, das ist sozusagen immer noch sehr geprägt von dem
deutschen Digitalansatz, den es zu kritisieren gilt generell.
Aber du könntest jetzt auch nicht so ohne weiteres irgendeine andere Struktur
aus dem Ärmel ziehen, wo nicht am Ende mehr oder weniger dieselben Personen
die Zielvorgabe wählen würden.
Also ich glaube jetzt nicht, dass der politische Rahmen hier generell so gewählt
ist, dass es zwangsläufig zu schlechten Ergebnissen kommen muss,
sondern ich sehe das halt hier dann doch eher noch so digital kulturell verankert,
dass es manchmal ein bisschen ruppig vorangeht.
Ich würde kurz noch eingreifen, die Zielvorgabe wäre ganz gut,
wenn die von der Politik kommt und die technische Realisierung gerne von der
Gematik, wo eben die Leute sitzen, die es auch am Ende umsetzen müssen.
Aber wenn wir uns an diesen Connectorspaß
erinnern, wenn dann da Sicherheitsentscheidungen getroffen werden,
Geräte nicht zu updaten und lieber neue zu verkaufen, das erschüttert natürlich
das Vertrauen in dieses Gremium enorm.
Also ich sag auch nicht, die sollen sich nicht anders verhalten,
ich sag nur, man müsste eigentlich aus der Struktur mehr machen können,
aber da enttäuschen sie leider noch ein wenig.
So jetzt ganz kurz hier mit den, so jetzt, das ist ja der entscheide Punkt,
jetzt sagt der, jetzt kommt der Epidemiologe und sagt, hier,
die Wissenschaft darf darauf zugreifen, aber das machen wir dann mit so einem Forschungspseudonym.
Also statt deinem Namen steht dann deine ID dran und jetzt dürfen die Leute,
darf die Wissenschaft zur Forschung diese Daten heranziehen.
Da wird es sicherlich tausende Details und so weiter geben, aber überhaupt das
zu ermöglichen hat eine Konsequenz und das ist.
Da ich ja nicht weiß, was die Wissenschaft morgen erforschen will und vor allem,
weil ich nicht weiß, welche Daten morgen in diese Akte kommen,
dass ich eine Struktur baue, die es letztendlich der Wissenschaft ermöglicht,
auf diese Daten zuzugreifen.
Und das heißt fundamental, die Datenhoheit ist nicht bei mir als Eignerin dieser Patientenakte.
In dem alten, ebenfalls nicht besonders guten System,
sagen wir jetzt halt eine ganze Menge Nachteile, liegt halt bei allen möglichen
Ärztinnen und Ärzten irgendwelche Daten, ich muss die im Zweifelsfall rübertragen
und so. Also auf jeden Fall fehlende Effizienz.
Auch da habe ich nicht so wirklich die Datenhoheit, aber ich weiß zumindest,
meine Daten, die bei der einen Zahnärztin liegen, die finden nicht ihren Weg
irgendwo anders hin, ohne dass ich die persönlich darüber trage.
Und die finden erst recht nicht irgendwie sich in Forschungen wieder,
wo dann auch noch von mehreren Ärztinnen, bei denen ich war,
die Daten zusammengetragen werden.
Und da bin ich jetzt irgendwie skeptisch, wenn das nämlich ermöglicht wird,
dann heißt es, der einst, das heißt es ist technisch möglich,
diese Daten zusammenzuführen und dann zu pseudonymisieren.
Dann, in dem Moment, wo es technisch möglich wird, ist alles,
was mich davor schützt, dass das irgendwelche anderen tun, ja nur noch das Gesetz.
Und das wird ja regelmäßig gerne geändert. Das heißt erweiterter Zugriff oder
weitere Stellen, das ist dann halt so ein Pharmakonzern, macht dann jetzt Forschung
und so. Das ist alles dann nur noch wenige Schritte entfernt.
Was ich vor allem sehe ist, wenn da jetzt statt deinem Namen eine ID ist,
schön und gut, aber mit dem Aggregationsniveau wird Anonymisierung eigentlich unmöglich.
Was heißt das? Was meine ich damit?
Nehmen wir als Beispiel männlich, Geburtsdatum Berlin.
Da werden in Berlin für jede oder weiblich Geburtsdatum Berlin jeweils nur noch
relativ wenige Personen zur Verfügung stehen.
Wenn du jetzt dann auch noch siehst, aha, das war die Hausärztin in Charlottenburg,
diese Daten hier beigetragen hat in die Akte, dann hast du im Zweifelsfall schon
die Möglichkeit zu einer eineindeutigen Identifikation der Person.
Also bei unstrukturierten Datenmengen, die da irgendwie reingeworfen werden
und irgendwelchen PDFs und hast du nicht gesehen,
wird so eine ID mit Sicherheit nicht dem Anonymisierungs- oder auch nur Pseudonymisierungsversprechen,
was da gemacht werden soll, gerecht werden können.
Ja.
Bist du noch da?
Ich bin noch da. Ich höre dir einfach zu.
Ja.
Musste ich auch mal ausreden lassen.
Und dann wird gesagt, okay, und da bin ich halt sehr,
wie soll man das sagen, wenn ich mir anschaue,
was die Gematik bisher so geliefert hat,
und wenn ich mir anschaue, wie es generell um dieses Land bestellt ist,
und wenn ich dann überlege, dass es hier ein Und wenn ich dann überlege,
dass es hier einen Gesundheitsminister gibt, der starken Schwerpunkt auf diese
Zugänglichmachung der Daten legt,
der im Zweifelsfall jede Maßnahme, die einen Zugriff auf die Daten irgendwie
wirklich mal unmöglich macht, sich der in den Weg stellen wird,
dann habe ich Sorge, dass das hier schief geht.
Ja. Ich meine, dann kommen sie noch mit und sagen, ja hier gibt ihr,
also, was ich, habe ich gar nicht erwähnt, dann sagen natürlich alle,
das wird auch von allen gefordert, Informed Consent, na klar,
für Datennutzung, DSGVO, informierte Einwilligung.
Jetzt muss man ja mal tatsächlich sagen, dass das Informed Consent,
das hat uns ja bisher echt weit getragen.
Also wo wären wir ohne Informed Consent? Wir haben irgendwie überall wo wir
hingehen müssen wir erstmal tausend Dinge wegklicken, um informiert zugestimmt
zu haben. Jetzt stellt ihr euch mal vor, das ist jetzt im medizinischen Bereich so.
Ist ja eigentlich auch jetzt schon so, ich meine, wenn du irgendwo beim Arzt
aufläufst, dann kriegst du auch als erstes mal so einen DSGVO Zettel,
ja klar. Und am Ende machst du es eh immer.
Also informt consent ist so dieses, jo machen wir, ist fertig.
Aber weißt du, was ich, das hat sich alles so angehört, ne?
Und weißt du aber, Tim, woran es am Ende scheitern wird? Dieses ganze System. AN.
An den Ärzten. Und da habe ich einen wunderschönen Mitschnitt für dich,
ich glaube aus der heute Nachrichten, nicht heute Show, wo ein Arzt mal so sagt,
was er von der Digitalstrategie hält.
Für die Ärzteschaft ist es sehr unattraktiv, weil die Vergütung extrem niedrig
ist. 1,67 Euro für das Befüllen bzw.
Weiterführen einer elektronischen Patientenakte ist kein Anreiz.
Wir machen uns hier immer über ein Datenmodell und Forschung und Digitalisierung
des Gesundheitswesens Gedanken.
Und dann kommt da so einer und sagt, 1,760 ist doch kein Anreiz,
lass mal was sehen, dann digitalisier ich euch auch das Gesundheitssystem.
Insofern müssen wir uns erstmal keine Gedanken machen, dass das hier allzu viel
schief geht, weil die haben keinen Anreiz.
Da hab ich mich mal ein bisschen eingelesen, da kann ich aber jetzt Fehler machen,
die Medizinerinnen unter unseren Hörern sagen Bescheid.
Also wenn ich das richtig verstanden habe, ist diese 1,67 tatsächlich pro Quartal
pro Patientin überhaupt in dieses Ding Daten einzufüllen.
Was mitunter heißen könnte, jetzt hast du irgendwie einen schweren Fall,
musst ganz viel in die EPA packen, dann kriegst du am Ende tatsächlich nur 1,67
für das gesamte Quartal.
Könnte man meinen, hui, tatsächlich relativ wenig Geld. Wenn du dir aber überlegst,
wie viele Patienten hast du denn so?
Und dann stellt sich natürlich auch die Frage, da wird jetzt davon ausgegangen,
dass das mit irgendeinem Aufwand verbunden wäre, Daten in der EPA zu hinterlegen.
Die Realität wird doch hoffentlich so sein, dass die Praxis bereits ein PMS,
ein Patientenmanagement-System hat.
Das ist das System, auf das die Ärzte zugreifen, wenn sie ins Behandlungszimmer
kommen und gucken und sagen, ah Herr Neumann, Sie waren ja vor zwei Jahren und
drei Monaten schon mal hier.
Und so tun, als hätten sie das aus ihrem Kopf. Und wissen, da haben wir uns
hinten den linken Backenzahn angeschaut.
Das haben wir ja ohnehin. Und jetzt würde ich eigentlich erwarten,
dass eine Realisierung am Ende ist, naja, okay, dieses Ding jetzt hier,
haben wir mal wieder ein Röntgenbild in das Patientenmanagementsystem gelegt.
Das ist ein, was weiß ich, ein Dokument von Schaffenshöhe oder ausreichender
Relevanz, dass wir das in die EPA legen und dann wird ein Häkchen dran gemacht
und der Rest passiert automatisch, oder?
Würde meinen wollen, ich vermute allerdings, dass es derzeit nun mal so ist,
dass es in dieser Arztsoftware einfach nochmal einen zusätzlichen Arbeitsschritt
darstellt diese EPA zu befüllen.
Und ich schließe ein wenig die Augen bei dem Gedanken daran wie das Userinterface
dafür wohl aussehen mag.
Du aber ein positives Nutzungserlebnis ist doch Zulassungsvorgabe.
Bisher aber nicht. Das liegt ja jetzt in der Digitalstrategie.
Und vielleicht ist das so einer dieser Argumente.
Ja natürlich, selbstverständlich müsste das eigentlich nur ein Fleck sein, Synchto EPA.
Ganz klar. Verstehst du? Alle Änderungen werden da einfach ...
Reingesynkt nur dann müsste natürlich dieser EPA auch ein entsprechendes Target
sein wo Reinsynken auch ein technisch leicht zu lösen das Problem ist,
wenn es sich dabei aber um so ein Uploadstore handelt ja wie so ein FTP Server,
immer noch nachdem der ganze Bearbeitungsvorgang mit dem Patienten abgeschlossen ist,
Du dann so die Dokumente einzeln nochmal in irgendeiner Untermaske markieren
musst und dann hochladen und dann nochmal DSGVO und nochmal irgendeine Seite abklicken.
Ja und dann kommt noch eine Fehlermeldung und wenn's nicht, dann funktioniert's
nicht und dann musst du es manuell aber nochmal probieren und dann sitzt du
da auch wirklich fünf Minuten davor.
Dann würde ich halt auch schreien, wenn ich dafür 1,67 Euro im Quartal bekomme,
weil das ist ja dann auch einfach wirklich geleistete Arbeitszeit für eine wirklich dumme Sache.
Und für das Software Update, die dieses in Anführungsstrichen Feature eingebracht
hat, hast du wahrscheinlich auch noch duddelig viel Geld für bezahlt.
Und das ist aber ehrlich gesagt glaube ich, also so würde ich erwarten, ist das.
Ja, natürlich musst du für diese Software irgendwie bezahlen,
du musst auch für diese TI Geschichte bezahlen, alles richtig, ja.
Und refinanziert wird das halt durch diese 1,67 Euro. Und wenn ich jetzt überlege,
wenn ich mir diese Connector Preise anschaue, ne, TI Connector,
also ich habe keine genaue Ahnung, wie viel jetzt Gematik-Anbindung eine Arztpraxis
im Jahr kostet, ne. Es werden ein paar tausend Euro sein.
Und wenn ich mir, wenn ich diese paar tausend Euro nehme und auf die Patienten
verlege, dann rechne ich damit, dass wir irgendwie so bei 1,67 Euro pro Patient landen.
Okay, hab ich jetzt nicht nachgerechnet, aber das ist ganz schön genau.
Also wäre jetzt mal so meine vorsichtige Schätzung, ja,
dass man, also natürlich klar,
da muss auf der anderen Seite wird Geld ausgegeben für diese Anbindung,
auf der anderen Seite wird abgerechnet und so und das ist alles super kompliziert,
aber ich stell mir gerade, also was wahrscheinlich nicht passieren wird,
ist das da ein Arzt sitzt und sagt, die Arbeit machen wir jetzt aber nicht mehr für 1,67€.
Also doch einer schon, das ist der dann da.
Also ich, keine Ahnung, vielleicht bin ich da auch selber so ein bisschen,
also das ist kein Anreiz, diesen Satz finde ich.
Ja gut, ich versuche das zu interpretieren aus der Erfahrungswelt von Ärzten.
Wir haben ja auch schon Kommentare dazu bekommen im Blog,
aber auch so hinten rum, immer mal wieder so Berichte aus der Arztpraxiswelt,
die dann einfach von ihren Phobien berichten, die sie entwickelt haben über
die Zeit im Umgang mit ihrer Praxissoftware.
Weil die einfach nicht up to date ist und ihnen einfache Dinge nicht leicht
macht und wenn das dann halt so ist, dass es ihnen das nicht leicht macht,
dann kann ich auch so eine Klage verstehen.
Würde ich ja auch beklagen beklage ich auch wenn software scheiße ist und einfache
dinge schwierig sind und wenn man sie oft machen muss hast du die ganze zeit das gefühlt.
Weißt du was ich mache, wenn ich so eine Software habe?
Das ist so ein bisschen wie Diesel vorglühen im Auto, weißt du?
Das willst du auch nicht mehr machen.
Ja genau deswegen, aber weißt du was ich mache, wenn ich so eine Software habe?
Wegschmeißen. Ich kaufe eine andere.
Ja aber das Problem ist, du kannst nicht mal eben die Praxissoftware in deiner
Arztpraxis von heute auf morgen austauschen und zweitens die andere ist ja auch scheiße.
Also ich glaube nicht, dass sich das viel gegenseitig nimmt und dass es da irgendein
Produkt gibt, was total überzeugend den Markt abräumt, weil alle Ärzte sich
die Finger danach lecken.
Es ist halt einfach so eine Branche und ich will das jetzt auch gar nicht so abwertend sagen,
ich bin mir relativ sicher, dass die Softwarehersteller da auch am Kämpfen sind,
weil sie sich natürlich auch in einem Bereich befinden,
der eben durch diese gesamte Gesetzeslage und durch diesen schwerfälligen Standardisierungsprozess
auch unter Anforderungsdruck stehen.
Ja und vielleicht teilweise einfach auch durch die Spezifikationen zu vollkommen
bekloppten Benutzerführungen gezwungen werden und es gar nicht einfacher machen können,
also da weiß ich jetzt auch wirklich zu wenig, das ist jetzt einfach alles von
mir so ein bisschen in die Welt gerendert,
was ich mir so, was ich schon woanders gesehen habe,
Und teilweise auch im medizinischen Bereich aber so generell aus der Software,
die sich in einer Domäne abspielt,
wo einfach die Anforderungen stark sind und du wirst es ja selber auch kennen,
allein schon Anforderungen von Unternehmen, was sie meinen,
was sie selber brauchen, die dann von Leuten gemacht werden,
die diese Prozesse gar nicht so richtig verstehen, bringt dann Dienstleister
auch in Rage, die es einfach mal, eben mal so richtig ordentlich machen würden,
aber steht ja im Pflichtenheft steht ja was anderes drin.
Und so dreht sich das halt alles im Kreis. Das ist einfach jetzt nicht so ein Bereich,
der sich mal so eben entwickeln kann und der eben dadurch,
dass er auch so ein super vertikaler Markt ist, also damit meine ich extrem
auf eine Branche und ihre Bedürfnisse zugeschnitten,
gibt's da jetzt auch nicht so viele Anbieter plus eben den begrenzten Spielraum,
den du einfach durch regulatorische Vorgaben hast und das macht es natürlich
dann auch schwierig dort kreativ modern am Start zu sein.
Dann haben alle PCs das kommt noch dazu also wie willst du da was erreichen?
Das ist doch alles Windows Software.
Ich find aber sehr gut das du da so klassische robotische Philosophie mit reinbringst
woanders ist auch scheiße.
So ist es doch, sag mal wie es ist.
Das geht übrigens, ich glaub woanders geht auch scheiße, ich mein,
einfach Straßenweisheit, aber geht so ein bisschen auf Frank Gose zurück,
der mit Jochen Malmsheimer vielleicht heute in der Sendung noch vorkommen könnte.
Ich würde sagen, von dem was wir bisher gesehen haben,
von der Thematik und in diesem Land mit Digitalisierung und so,
habe ich den Eindruck, dass wir vielleicht noch nicht so reif sind,
diese Entscheidung jetzt zu treffen.
Weißt, was ich meine?
Ich könnte mir sogar vorstellen, dass es einen verantwortungsvollen Weg gibt,
diese Ziele zu erreichen, technisch.
Und ich glaube auch, dass das sogar Menschen möglich wäre, ja,
so eine elektronische Patientenakte mit, die Patientin hat die Hoheit über diese
Daten, es kommt nicht ohne ihre explizite Einwilligung dazu,
dass Forschung stattfindet.
Und dann wird der vielleicht auch mit so skurrilen Dingern, wie das dann zum
Beispiel in der U-Bahn steht, so, nehmen Sie an unserer Studie teil.
Scannen Sie diesen QR-Code mit Ihrer ePAR-App und klicken Sie, ja, ich will.
Und Sie kriegen 20 Euro auf Ihr ePAR-Konto. Da können Sie beim nächsten Mal
beim Arztbesuch in Igelleistungen sparen.
Kriegen Sie Herzchen an der Theke. Könnte ich mir, kann man ja alles machen.
Ich glaube, dass das so eine, dass es technisch sogar möglich wäre,
so etwas zu bauen und in ordentlich und gut.
Ich traue das nur irgendwie diesem Land nicht zu.
Ja?
Und erst recht nicht unter einer, ähm,
unter einem, ja,
dieser Hauruck-Mentalität, die in diesem
Sektor notwendigerweise und auch berechtigterweise natürlich herrscht,
dass man jetzt sagt so, nein, keinen Tag mehr weiter so.
Jetzt digitalisieren, gib ihm. Das wird ja eh schon alles die ganze Zeit von
DrLibs und was nicht alles überholt. Diese ganze Branche ist sturmreif,
da kommt jetzt irgendwann mal jemand und macht was.
Und das wird dann im Zweifel, da sehe ich die Gefahr, dass jetzt wie bei den
bisherigen Leuchtturmprodukten an Health-Apps und so, dass da halt totaler Murksball rauskommt.
Denk an die Digas, diese digitalen Apps da, das ist auch wieder ein Kapes,
was sich die Zerforschung vor ein paar Monaten angeschaut hat.
Und jetzt kommen die und sagen jawoll, ähm, krempeln wir mal die Ärmel hoch
und klimpern was schönes auf der Tastatur zusammen.
Entweder landet das in irgendeiner nicht funktionierenden Versenkung oder das
wird jetzt alles von irgend so einem Studenten in PHP geschrieben.
Und irgendwo dazwischen sehe ich halt nichts, weißt du? Das heißt ich gucke
da drauf und denke mir so, oh Junge, Junge.
Wir können auf diesem Sand diese Sandburg noch nicht bauen.
Also es ist, mir hat gerade jemand irgendwie, der aus Deutschland kommt,
in Holland lebt, irgendwie von seinem Arzt Realitäten dort berichtet und da
ist das genauso, wie man das haben will.
Weißt du da hast du da einfach elektronisch alles zentral gespeichert,
wechselst DNA's, sie wissen schon
irgendwie Bescheid, du brauchst dein Medikament irgendwie verlängert,
da klickst du dir irgendwie online und dann kriegst du das an einem Medikamentenautomaten
an der Apotheke ausgegeben, wenn du da mit deiner Karte rangehst.
Das sind ja einfach Vorstellungen, da denkst du ja da sind wir in zehn Jahren noch nicht.
So das ist das eine. Also erstens gibt es schon in Europa. Ich weiß jetzt nicht
überall und so weiter manche Länder sicherlich auch anders oder genauso schlimm
wie Deutschland aber es definitiv gibt es bessere Vorbilder die das irgendwie
gelöst bekommen und das halt auch in einem europäischen Datenschutzrahmen.
Ja, das kommt ja noch dazu. Und außerdem...
Sollte mal jeder sich mal kurz über sein smartphone neigen was dort schon alles
an health standards implementiert worden ist in den letzten jahren also gerade
hier so die ganze health implementierung von apple auf dem iphone wo ja auch
tonnenweise daten schon gespeichert werden können.
Das folgt selbstverständlich allen, also internationalen Standards.
Also das ist sozusagen jetzt nicht nur so wie Apple das macht,
sondern das basiert tatsächlich auf akzeptierten internationalen Austausch und
Datenspeicherstandards.
Und das ist natürlich ohnehin die Infrastruktur, die wir letzten Endes integrieren
müssen. Sprich ich denke, dass die ganze Digitalisierung über kurz oder lang
ohnehin von diesen Geräten definiert werden wird.
Das ist die zeigen ganz klar das
gilt im übrigen auch für diese Diskussion mit dem Personalausweis also das ist
ja gar nicht anders mehr vorstellbar als dass diese Universal Digital Geräte
das Interface sind wie sie es im Gesundheitsbereich werden so wie sie es heute
im Finanzbereich schon sind.
Ich kann halt mit meiner scheiß Uhr irgendwie mal kurz am Terminal wedeln und
dann habe ich mir irgendwie eine Currywurst im Stadion gekauft.
Das geht, muss ich nicht unbedingt machen wollen, aber es funktioniert und es
ist auch sicher und arbeitet mit biometrischen Merkmalen und pipapo die aber
privat auf dem Telefon sind.
Die technischen Lösungen an sich sind schon da und müssen es müsste ich eigentlich
mehr das Gesundheitssystem an diese Standards anpassen und ich glaube,
dass wir uns hier immer noch in so einem Rennen befinden, den Old Way,
wie wir das hier schon immer gemacht haben in irgendeiner Form digital abzubilden,
während sich der Rest der Welt eigentlich schon pragmatisch auf neues sinnvolles
Modell geeinigt hat und zusieht, dass das eigene System sich an diese Standards anpasst.
Also ich stecke nicht wirklich tief drin aber ich finde es einfach beklagenswert
wie wenig da vorangeht und ich mache mir auch ehrlich gesagt jetzt von so einer
neuen Digitalstrategie mache mir jetzt erstmal wenig Hoffnung,
ich sage nur wake me up wenn es so weit ist so,
dann nehme ich das gerne zur Kenntnis aber bis dahin bleibe ich bei meiner generellen
Einschätzung Deutschland digital wird nichts mehr.
Okay, dem würde ich zustimmen. Jetzt gibt es noch einen Phänomenbereich,
der natürlich auch nochmal berücksichtigt werden muss. So eine Patientenakte,
die wird mit der Zeit ganz schön lang.
Die soll dich ja idealerweise dein Leben lang begleiten.
Und dann gibt es so bestimmte Diagnoschen, die man vielleicht nicht so gerne mit allen teilt.
Bestimmte stigmatisierte Diagnosen sagen wir jetzt gar keine spezifischen zu nennen.
Jetzt sagen die Grünen, ja, das wollen wir aber, dass das maskiert werden kann.
Beispiel HIV. So jetzt ist andererseits ist das natürlich, das ist eine Information,
dass du HIV-positiv bist, die potenziell vielleicht jeden Arzt interessieren
sollte, der mit dir hantiert.
Zu Blutkontakt oder sonst dem käme. Das heißt,
diese Idee, wir lassen jetzt hier Sachen drin maskieren,
die klingt für den Einzelfall, also für den einzelnen Fall immer total naheliegend und sinnvoll,
bis dann der Moment ist, in dem du das vielleicht nicht, wo es dann nicht wünschenswert
ist, dass es maskiert ist, Psychische Erkrankung.
Riesending. Stell dir mal vor,
jeder Arzt, den du besuchst, weiß sofort, keine Ahnung, vor 27 Jahren bist du
schon mal mit einer manischen Phase aufgefallen.
Oder vor drei Jahren hattest du längere Zeit Depressionen oder du nimmst jetzt noch Antidepressiva.
Was du dem erzählst über deinen Zustand, wird ja potenziell automatisch gefärbt
sein von dem Eindruck, den er jetzt durch diese andere Diagnose von dir hat.
Und auch da entstehen wieder so, also über die Jahre stigmatisierende Dinge in dieser Akte sammeln.
Da entstehen auch wirklich, glaube ich, Herausforderungen, die noch nicht ganz klar sind.
Ja gut, aber das ist natürlich auch eine Unterstellung, dass solche Informationen
bei Ärzten dazu führen, dass du dann automatisch in einer Stigmatisierung landest.
Also ich würde mal meinen … Das ist keine Unterstellung, das ist eine Realität.
Ja, aber das ist die Bedrohung durch eine... also ist die Möglichkeit einer
solchen Stigmatisierung, die ja nicht...
Das kannst du jetzt für wahrscheinlich halten, aber es ist nicht auf jeden Fall so.
Besser als ein Unwissen über deinen kranken Vergangenheit.
Ich wollte gerade nicht sagen, dass das einer von beiden, das ist genau die
Abwägung. Das kommt halt drauf an, wem ich da jetzt gerade gegenüber dritte.
Ich hab zum Beispiel das Problem, ich weiß nicht, ob dir das auch so geht,
aber ich hab ja keine elektronische Patientenakte mein Leben lang geführt.
Ich hab gar keine Patientenakte.
Und ganz ehrlich, ich geh zum Arzt und die fragen mich irgendwie,
haben sie in den letzten drei Jahren eine Operation gehabt oder so.
Ich so, äh, muss mal nachdenken.
Oder haben sie in den letzten fünf Jahren Beschwerden in diesem Bereich.
Welche Medikamente haben sie eingenommen?
Zack, zack, diagnostizieren wir dir eine Demenz.
Ja ich weiß nichts davon, ich merke mir das einfach nicht,
ich schreibe mir das auch nicht auf, was eigentlich ein Fehler ist,
also ich kann euch das auch allen nur raten, irgendwie macht das,
führt ein medizinisches Logbuch, führt eure eigene elektronische Patientenbank,
weil der Staat kriegt's ja eh nicht hin und sowas ist schon ganz praktisch.
Also ganz ehrlich, hätte ich da mehr Awareness gehabt, hätte ich mir von Anfang
an eine Datenbank für gemacht.
Das wär's wirklich gewesen. Weil das kann schon hilfreich sein.
Auch so bei der Eigendiagnostizierung.
Ich vergesse auch manchmal bestimmte Malesen. So, die ich hab.
Dann bin ich beim Arzt und so.
Ist doch gut, wenn du die vergisst, ist doch in Ordnung.
Ja, ne, so Sachen die nur ab und zu auftreten und so und dann hast du mal deinen
Arzttermin und dann so ja ist noch irgendwas, ne sonst ist eigentlich alles in Ordnung.
Und in dem Moment wo ich zur Tür rausgehe, denk ich mir so, ah war ja noch dit
und dit und dit, das wolltest du nochmal ansprechen und so weiter,
alles so Sachen wo du nicht weißt und so, weißt du?
Und am Ende stellt sich das dann vielleicht als irgendwas raus,
ja werden sie mal vor zwei Jahren angekommen, ja das hatte ich seit drei Jahren
auf dem Zettel, aber halt nicht auf dem einen elektronischen Patientenachtenzettel.
Es wäre ja auch ganz gut, wenn man das selber trimmen könnte,
wenn man sozusagen auch selber sozusagen seinen eigenen Beobachtungsbefund,
so eine Selbstbeobachtung auch einfach in so ein Logfile reinschreiben kann,
damit das dann auch einfach schon da und reproduzierbar ist.
Ich denke damit wäre allen geholfen.
Not to self. Ja, no to self. Das sind schon so alles Aspekte und ehrlich gesagt,
ja okay gut, da geh ich irgendwie ein Stück weit mit und man kann da überall so Risiken sehen.
Aber ganz ehrlich, in unserem Feld und das müssen wir uns auch immer wieder mal klar machen.
Ich bin großer Freund dieser Balance zwischen Chancen und Risiken.
Also wir diskutieren hier oft Sachen, wo man sagen kann, oh das kann aber,
weißt du, das kann ja folgende negative Auswirkungen haben.
Und ich glaube, dass wir so ein bisschen auch als Szene, so ein bisschen so
als Kenner der Details immer so ein bisschen dazu tendieren,
die negativen Aspekte überzubetonten.
Ich sag nicht die gibt's nicht und ich sag auch nicht die muss man nicht thematisieren.
Die Frage ist halt immer nur was ist die Balance aus allem. Und das ist natürlich
auch eine Kritik die oft an uns so herangetragen wird.
Oft bildet sich das über diese Datenschutzdebatten aber ich würde das mal davon
losgelöst generell sagen.
Du hast ja immer so dieses Problem in dem Moment wo du irgendwas besonders gut
kennst und das ist so deine Domäne,
Dann kommt man schnell so mit ja aber habt ihr das bedacht und ihr kennt euch
ja da nicht aus und so weiter und so ist das wahrscheinlich überall in der Pferdezucht oder im,
keine Ahnung also egal in welches Feld du reingehst,
wenn du zu den Experten kommst und denen irgendeinen Plan vorstellst,
wie du in einem bestimmten Bereich Verbesserung einführen willst,
dann kommen sie alle mit ihrem Bedenkenträgertum und sagen so ja aber,
das könnte ich mir aber tausend Szenarien vorstellen wo das in die Hose gehen kann.
So ja okay gut kannst du vielleicht so aber ich könnte mir auch hunderttausend
Szenarien vorstellen wo das echt sinnvoll sein könnte das mal so zu machen.
Und das ist schon eine Balance und generell bin ich einfach ein großer Freund
von der Betonung auch der Chancen
und dass man das halt auch sehen muss weil das ist ja eben auch so,
wir verpassen hier glaube ich mehr als wir zu befürchten haben.
Okay, also ich würde allem zustimmen und ich finde auch, dass wir wahrscheinlich
heute in der Sendung eine ganz gute Kurve gekriegt haben, zu sagen,
ja klar, natürlich willst du ein digitalisiertes Gesundheitssystem haben, ja.
Wir werden das nicht ...
Ja, oder es wird noch viel schlimmer, wenn wir es nicht machen.
Gleichzeitig, und ich hoffe es ist auch klar geworden,
dass wir uns dem nicht vollständig dagegen stellen, aber gleichzeitig an dieser
Stelle von diesen Leuten fundamentale Entscheidungen treffen zu lassen,
Er scheint mir gefährlich, er scheint mir waghalsig.
Ich glaube es gibt eine ganze Menge, die zum Beispiel Ärztinnen und Ärzte und
das ganze Personal, was da noch in so einem Gesundheitssystem drum herum tanzt
und die eigentliche Arbeit macht, besser wissen als wir.
Die können zum Beispiel sagen, pass mal auf, folgendes wäre eine Anforderung,
die ich habe. Zum Beispiel, wenn jetzt hier dieses Notfallmedizinerinnen möchten,
brauchen Einblick in die Patientenakte.
Wenn man jetzt einfach nur zu denen hingeht und sagt, sag mal welche Punkte,
dann werden die nämlich sagen, ja pass auf, die lebensbedrohlichen Krankheiten,
Herz-Lunge, Infektionsschutz, wenn der notwendig ist und dat und dat und dat und dat.
Vielleicht irgendwelche Stents oder sonst was. Das was in der einen Situation
medizinischer Notfall nicht ansprechbare Personen oder von mir aus ist die Person auch ansprechbar,
aber gerade nicht in der Lage ihre Krankengeschichte kurz mal eben zu erörtern.
Diese Informationen, die wären gut die zu haben. dann könnte man sich nämlich
von der technischen Seite sagen,
okay, pass auf, um das zu ermöglichen, führen wir folgende Funktionalität ein,
ja, und die bildet sich folgendermaßen ab in unserem Datenraum,
den wir hier haben, und die wird folgendermaßen realisiert, und die ist von
mir aus auch kompatibel mit dem, was Apple eh schon macht, und so weiter und so fort.
Ich habe aber die Befürchtung, dass hier, wie so oft,
gesagt wird, ach, das ist irgendwie alles viel zu kompliziert,
Lass mal lieber irgendwelche Schutzmaßnahmen bauen, die alle total nerven.
Zum Beispiel diese ganze Connector Nummer, habe ich nie ganz verstanden,
warum ich ein Gematik-Connector haben soll.
Also der Zweck dieses Connectors in der Architektur leuchtet mir nicht ein,
wenn auf dem gleichen Rechner, der hinter dem Connector hängt,
den ganzen Tag, übrigens ohne Altersverifikation, im Internet gesurft wird.
Und wer weiß, was die sich da anschauen.
Das heißt, da ist das Thread-Model auch irgendwie völlig daneben.
Und die Operationen gucken sie sich natürlich an.
Und diese Live-Übertragung im Internet. Doktor-Spiele im Internet.
Und das heißt so ein informiertes Grüppchen, dass man sagt, so kann man das ordentlich machen.
Und das ist doch eigentlich der Grund, warum jetzt der Aufschrei, in Anführungszeichen,
der leih-, der stille Aufschrei bei den Datenschützerinnen, bei den IT-Security-Leuten
kommt, bei insbesondere denen, wie jetzt sagen wir mal hier,
Flüppke, ähm, Martin Schier, die sich den Krempe ja auch schon seit Jahren angucken.
Und sagen so, oh, äh, Leute,
ganz ehrlich, ihr habt ja schon ein paar ganz gute Ideen gehabt,
aber vielleicht überschätzt ihr da gerade euer Brusthaar.
Ja, vielleicht, so was.
Davon hängt das ab, ja.
Jetzt machen wir hier alles digital, okay. Okay, vielleicht hört er nochmal
ein bisschen auf Leute, die, ne, das ist mein Unbehagen.
Und dieses Unbehagen lässt sich, muss man auch sagen, eben anhand einer Digitalstrategie,
noch nicht festmachen. Oder also das lässt sich nicht konkret sagen,
so dieser Teil der Digitalstrategie, den finde ich nicht in Ordnung.
Ich kann mir nur vorstellen, dieses mit dem Daten werden der Wissenschaft zugänglich gemacht,
da sehe ich ein großes Risiko, dass da halt das Kind mit dem Bade ausgeschüttet wird,
statt vielleicht moderne Technologien zur Anwendung zu bringen,
die es wirklich vielleicht ordentlich ermöglichen würden, aber davon höre ich hier wenig.
Das wäre meine diplomatische Positionierung zu diesem Sachverhalt.
Wollen wir dann mal weiterkommen in unserer Thesis?
Also wir haben, es gibt die gleiche Diskussion, das ist ja auch das Schöne,
gibt es auch nochmal auf EU-Ebene, deswegen bricht Deutschland jetzt hier schnell
vor, um noch schnell irgendwie eine Strategie zu haben.
Zum European Health Data Space soll das ja dann auf europäischer Ebene irgendwie
zusammengepresst werden.
Dazu positioniert sich Edri. Edri hat da ein Forderungspapier,
und zwar die Make the European Health Data Space Serve Patients and Research.
Great again.
Ja, Great Again ist natürlich... So was sagen sie?
Erstens, für die Weitergabe von Daten muss auf jeden Fall Konsent gegeben werden,
also der informt Konsent, gut.
Ich begrenze die Definition, was Gesundheitsdaten sind.
Sie kritisieren, dass sie zu breit diese Definition ist und sagen,
die Definition von Gesundheitsdaten soll eingeschränkt werden auf das,
was tatsächlich direkten Bezug zur Gesundheit und medizinischer Pflege hat.
Ökonomischer Status, sozialer Status, professionelles Leben dürfen nicht mit
da rein definiert werden.
Die erlaubten Nutzungsarten sollen präzise und legitim definiert sein.
Dass man eben sagt, nicht so zu Forschungszwecken darf darauf zugegriffen werden,
sondern zu In diesem Fall, ja, das Ergebnis muss sein, dass es klar ist,
nicht kommerzielle akademische Forschung mit nicht proprietären Forschungsergebnissen
wäre so ein Mindestpunkt.
Dann natürlich muss die Datensicherheit eine Top Priorität sein,
tut mir leid, natürlich.
Also wenn da jetzt irgendwas gebaut werden soll, wo von 80 Millionen Arztbesuchenden
in Deutschland und weiß ich wie viel in Europa Daten auf einen Haufen geworfen
werden und einem Datenregime unterzogen werden,
Da wäre das schon nicht schlecht, wenn man auch die Leute mitreden lässt,
die von der IT-Sicherheit ein bisschen Ahnung haben.
Und vielleicht diese Leute auch der Gestalt mit einbringen, dass sie nicht einen
inhärenten Interessenskonflikt durch ihre Arbeitgeberin haben.
Okay, also auf EU-Ebene haben wir das auch. Khaleesi wird uns da sicherlich
in den nächsten Folgen nochmal darüber informieren.
Kommen wir zu den noch schlechteren Nachrichten.
Was denn?
Ja, der in Ravensburg, kennst du das?
Ravensburg?
Kennst du das? Ravensburg? Das ist im Ländle, glaube ich.
Da wo die Puzzle herkommen.
Da kommt die Puzzle her, ja.
Da ist es also passiert, dass das Handy eines Beschuldigten mit einem vorher
erzwungenen Fingerabdruck,
Entsperrt wurde Und zwar
haben sie einen Verdächtigen gehabt und haben gesagt okay im
rahmen einer erkennungsdienstlichen maßnahme Nehmen wir
jetzt mal einen fingerabdruck von dem Und aber das haben sie begründet mit der
erkennungsdienstlichen maßnahme jetzt hatten sie aber nun mal den fingerabdruck
Dann haben sie eine biometrische kopie also sehr einfach dann eben den fingerabdruck
so umgebaut dass der oder so produziert,
dass sie damit das Mobiltelefon entsperren konnten.
Sagst du mal so ein Video vom CCC, wie das geht?
Da gibt es mehrere Videos, ja. Es gibt die Videos von Starbuck,
wir haben nachher auch nochmal im Labor.
Klar, ne? Aber, und jetzt, das findet ja den juristischen Aspekt eher Das war
sehr lustig. Also, dass das technisch möglich ist, wurde gezeigt.
Das hat hier die Polizei gemacht.
Und dann wurde dagegen geklagt.
Und dann sagte erst, dass wahrscheinlich, was ist das denn dann?
Erste Instanz hat gesagt, ja ne kann man machen, ja. Und dann jetzt die zweite
Instanz hat das wieder bestätigt. Das Amtsgericht, also das Landgericht hat
gesagt, ja ne war in Ordnung was das Amtsgericht da gemacht hat.
Jetzt stellt sich aber die Frage, Wie kommt das Gericht denn zu der Idee,
dass es dafür jetzt schon eine rechtliche Grundlage gäbe?
Und das finde ich halt relativ schwierig, weil das Handy hat eine biometrische Sperre.
Und den Fingerabdruck erlangen sie ja zu Identifizierungszwecken und Zwecken
der Nachweisung einer Tat.
Und dann sagen sie, da sie in diesem Tatzusammenhang, wie der Beschuldigte war,
Da ging es um den Handel mit Substanzen, mit denen er nicht hätte handeln dürfen.
Und da haben sie gesagt, in dem Sinne nehmen wir diesen festgestellten Fingerabdruck,
den wir jetzt haben und von dem wir eine Kopie anfertigen und damit das Mobiltelefon
entsperren, kommt dem eine Identifizierungsfunktion zu.
Die Identifizierungsfunktion wird hier im Unterschied zum klassischen Fall allerdings
nicht unmittelbar zum Führen des Tatnachweises verwendet, sondern als Zwischenziel
zur Erlangung der für den Nachweis erforderlichen gespeicherten Daten.
Inwieweit die Maßnahme notwendig für das Strafverfahren ist,
ist eine Frage nach der zu thematisierenden Verhältnismäßigkeit.
Die Verwendung von biometrischen Körpermerkmalen zur Entschlüsselung von Daten
durch einen Abgleich mit dem im Endgerät hintergelegten Schlüsselmerkmal ist
deshalb auch vom Wortleut umfasst." Also das Das Gericht meint,
dass es quasi in der jetzigen Rechtslage bereits eine Grundlage dazu gebe.
Und das halte ich für nicht wirklich den Fall.
Ja, I'm not a lawyer. Das ist interessant.
Sie beziehen sich auf welche Gesetzlage? das Entsperren des Speichermediums
ist ein notwendiges Zwischenziel.
Naja, also nachvollziehbarerweise ist das für die Polizei ein Zwischenziel, gar keine Frage.
Und ich meine, hättest du jetzt irgendwie dein Passwort irgendwo auf den Zettel
geschrieben, dann würden sie es ja auch verwenden wollen, würden.
So könnte man das ja quasi mal deuten.
Also das zeigt generell natürlich jetzt so ein bisschen natürlich auch das Risikofeld
auf was halt biometrische Erkennungsmerkmale machen.
Die sind alleine jetzt erstmal nicht unbedingt etwas was die Sachen sicherer
macht, sondern erstmal praktischer.
Dein Telefon mit dem Fingerabdruck zu entsperren oder mit dem Gesicht ist ja
eher eine Funktion, die dich dazu bringen soll überhaupt Passwörter zu benutzen.
Weil wenn du jetzt so einen langen 20 buchstabigen String da jedes mal eintippen
musst um mal kurz zu schauen ob du eine Nachricht bekommen hast,
das führt eben dazu, dass weniger Leute überhaupt so einen Schutz haben.
Also es ist ja immer mit Security so eine Frage, eine Abwägung auch mit Convenience
und je nach Gerät hast du ja auch nicht nur so eine biometrische Funktion.
Also ich wundere mich in solchen Fällen halt immer, wie ist es denen denn überhaupt
gelungen das Telefon in einem Zustand zu bekommen, wo ein Einloggen mit einem
Fingerabdruck überhaupt noch möglich ist.
Wahrscheinlich ein Android.
Kann gut sein, aber so ein iPhone drückst du halt zweimal an die Seite und nach
einer bestimmten Zeit geht es dann halt auch nicht mehr.
Das musst du allerdings auch wissen und ja genau diese ablaufende Zeit.
Ich finde, also ich muss tatsächlich, du hast einen wichtigen Aspekt benannt
und das kann ich hier auch verraten, glaube ich.
Der der Starbuck, der ja dieses ganze Biometrie Research macht und der auch bei dem,
Bei dem iPhone 4 war das ja glaube ich den Touch ID Sensor umgangen hat und so.
Der nutzt diese Funktionalität aus genau dem Grund auch.
Also er nutzt die biometrische Identifikation, weil er dadurch einen längeren
Pincode auf seinem Telefon haben kann.
Was ich aber gerne hätte wären Techniken und ich hoffe,
dass die jetzt endlich in Reaktion auf dieses Urteil mal kommen, wo man sagt,
okay pass auf, entweder du entsperrst dieses Telefon mit dem ganz langen Passwort,
Oder ich kriege ein biometrisches Merkmal von dir und dann musst du nur vier
Ziffern eingeben zum Beispiel.
Und davon hast du dann drei Versuche, sonst geht es wieder zurück auf den langen
Weg. Also das Biometrie, der Weg wird zu einem kürzeren, kürzeren Entwickler.
Also dass du so ein Second Fence hast sozusagen.
Genau, also Biometrie als ein zweiter Faktor,
der mir, der mir, ja als ein halber Faktor,
der mir sagt, der sagt, okay, pass auf, du musst nicht den langen Code eingeben,
sondern ich hab ja schon mal, die erste Hürde hast du genommen und dann würde
ich gerne einstellen können, das gilt für, sagen wir mal, drei Stunden.
Drei Stunden ist die Zeit, die ich der Polizei jetzt nicht zutrauen würde,
meinen Fingerabdruck ordentlich zu klonen.
Oder jetzt kommt natürlich noch ein viel erschwerenderes Problem hinzu,
was nämlich hier noch gar nicht so richtig berücksichtigt ist.
Die meisten Telefone heute, oder viele Telefone heute, zum Beispiel iPhones,
haben ja gar keinen Fingerabdrucksensor mehr. Die haben Sichterkennung.
Und da gibt es dieses wunderschöne Feature, die funktioniert nur,
wenn du auch wirklich hinschaust. Das heißt man muss sich echt mal antrainieren,
dass wenn einem jemand ein Telefon vor das Gesicht hält, dass man da nicht hinguckt.
Was ich glaube sehr schwierig ist im Fall der Fälle.
Also so ein Oh Telefon guck mal was ist das denn und du guckst da kurz hin und das Ding ist entsperrt.
Das hat ein trainierter Polizist, wenn der das geübt hat und du das zum ersten
Mal dich in so einer blöden Situation befindest, dann geht das glaube ich ganz Rucki zucki.
Das kann schon sein, ich meine da musst du natürlich dann auch einfach mal gucken
wie deine OPSEC so aussieht, also deine Operational Security.
Du hättest gerne einen zweiten Passcode genau, ist ein Weg, also kannst ja mal
zu Apple schreiben, dass du gerne noch so ein paar Dealer Options hättest.
Ich werd einfach zu oft hops genommen.
Was heißt Dealer Options?
Ich wette, du hast Tops genommen. Baut mal was ein.
Vielleicht müssten die Polizisten auch so ein Sender tragen,
dass das iPhone dann merkt, oh Lockdown.
So was. Aber es ist, also wir haben jetzt viel darüber nachgelächelt,
wie, darf Polizei an unser Gerät oder nicht.
Wir dürfen nicht vergessen, was hier stattfindet, ist ja die Verletzung eines Grundrechts.
Nämlich das Grundrecht auf die Vertraulichkeit und Integrität informationstechnischer Systeme.
Das heißt, hier hat die Polizei das Mittel der erkennungsdienstlichen Behandlung missbraucht,
um die Grundrechte dieses beschuldigten Menschen zu verletzen, und zwar erheblich.
Und das finde ich, also allein da denke ich, dass wir nicht sagen,
dass dieses Landgericht Ravensburg nicht zum Ergebnis kommen kann,
dass ein derartiger krasser Grundrechtseinschnitt über Umwege,
In dem Maße irgendwie von der aktuellen Rechtsprechung, sagen wir mal,
im Interesse oder in der Absicht der Gesetzgeberin läge. Das kann ich mir einfach
nicht vorstellen. Das ist, finde ich, eine Frechheit.
Ja, ich bin gespannt, ob das nochmal höher getragen wird auf der Gerichtsbarkeit,
weil das ist sicherlich etwas, was schon mal auf höchster Ebene entschieden werden sollte.
Das sollte sicherlich auf höchster Ebene entschieden werden und dann wissen
wir auch, was egal wie die Entscheidung ist oder wenn die Entscheidung dem entgegen
steht, dann wissen wir schon, was aus dem Innenministerium als nächstes kommt.
Kommen wir zu den Kurzmeldungen.
Radio 3 Land wehrt sich. Ich weiß gar nicht, ob ich, ich glaube das hatten wir hier schon erwähnt,
dass die sich gegen diese völlig beknackte Razzia,
die da bei Ihnen im Hause stattgefunden hat, Hausdurchsuchungen in den Redaktionsräumen
wegen eines Links, dass die sich das nicht gefallen lassen und da mit der Hilfe
der Gesellschaft für Freiheitsrechte auch gegen vorgehen.
Völliger, also haben wir jetzt öfter gesagt, da gibt es jetzt den Auftakt, gehen sie gegen vor.
Und setzen sich zur Wehr. Und dann gibt es noch eine, ja, im weitesten Sinne
eine relativ wichtige angekündigte Gesetzesänderung.
Und zwar haben wir hier das, normalerweise würden wir das hier vielleicht gar
nicht behandeln, aber weil es im Rahmen der Diskussion um die Chatkontrolle
öfter mal Thema war, Untertitel von Stephanie Geiges.
Es gab eine Veränderung von der Großen Koalition am § 184b des Strafgesetzbuches.
Und da haben sie gesagt, sie möchten auch die mittelbare Förderung des sexuellen
Missbrauchs von Kindern und Jugendlichen durch die Entsprechung von Darstellungen
schärfer sanktionieren.
Und haben gesagt, wir entfernen hier quasi die Möglichkeit, etwas mal durchgehen
zu lassen und sagen, wir machen das ist ein Verbrechen mit Mindestfreiheitsstrafe von einem Jahr.
Und damit ist es so, dass die Ermittler nicht mehr sagen können,
wir bringen das nicht vor Gericht.
Also es gibt quasi Fälle, wenn die keine so hohe Strafe haben,
dann überlässt man den Ermittlern einen bestimmten Spielraum zu sagen,
naja okay, das wollen wir jetzt hier zu Ende durchverfolgen oder nicht.
Wenn die Mindeststrafe aber ein Jahr ist, können die Ermittler nicht mehr sagen,
oh ich habe hier einen Anfangsverdacht, ich ermittle jetzt nicht mehr oder oh
ich habe einen Anfangsverdacht, ich bringe das jetzt nicht mehr vor Gericht.
Das hatte zur Konsequenz, das ist der Fall, den Khaleesi öfter mal angesprochen
hat, ich auch, dass sehr viele Jugendliche auf einmal unter diesen Strafverdacht
gefallen sind und entsprechend auch verfolgt wurden.
Weil die Jugendlichen.
Darstellungen von Jugendlichen verbreitet haben. Das heißt der größere Teil
der Ermittlungen wegen Verbreitung von Pornografie von Kindern und Jugendlichen
richtete sich gegen Kinder und Jugendliche.
Diesem Missstand wollen die Justizministerinnen und der Justizminister offenbar entgegentreten.
Ja, das heißt, sie haben sich schon darauf geeinigt, dass sie diesen Paragraf
184 B StGB korrigieren wollen,
um die sogenannten Schulhoffälle nicht mehr als Verbrechen verfolgen zu lassen.
Viel Spaß dabei.
Ist jetzt netzpolitisch erstmal nur ein peripheres Thema, aber weil wir diesen
Sachverhalt öfter hier angesprochen haben, wollte ich das der Vollständigkeit
halber mal erwähnt haben.
Alright. Haben wir damit alles erwähnt?
Ja 1,67 Euro.
Ich hab mal geguckt übrigens Tim, diese, ist es denn jetzt ein Baumwollsack?
Nur wenn er mehr als 36 Zentimeter Umfang hat.
Haben die wahrscheinlich oder?
Also du meinst jetzt keinen Beutel oder was?
Also ein Beutel ist ein flexibles, check, vollflächiges, check,
raumbildendes, check, Packmittel bis 2700 Quadratzentimeter Zuschnitt.
Also das sind nicht mehr als 2700 Quadratzentimeter.
Es ist ein Baumwollbeutel.
Ja, so. Sack ist flexibel, vollflächig, beim Befüllen raumbildend,
mindestens 36 cm Umfang.
Wobei 36 cm Umfang ist jetzt auch nicht so viel.
Ist ja nichts. Umfang. Das ist ja schon.
Ich würde vorschlagen.
Es ist sowohl. Es ist ein Sackbeutel oder ein Beutelsack.
Ich würde vorschlagen bestellt doch einfach mal einen und sagt uns dann was das ist.
Genau wir müssen das unbedingt rauskriegen damit wir das korrekt dran schreiben können.
Hat es aber recht haben ein paar Leute bestellt. Bei Wipen nicht so viele wie es angemessen wäre.
Bei Wipen nicht so viele wie es angemessen wäre und denkt dran ihr müsst den
ja auch befüllen um dann den Umfang zu messen.
Kann man ja nicht beim Lernen, doch kann man auch.
Da könnt ihr doch ein paar T-Shirts dazu kaufen, die könnt ihr da reinstopfen.
Das ist so richtig schön, dass es sich richtig beim Befüllen raumbildend verhält das Packmittel.
Vielleicht sollte man draufschreiben, raumbildendes Packmittel.
Raumbildendes Packmittel.
Ja dann kannst du es Sack nennen, dann kannst du auch Jut sagen,
ist egal. Ja es ist ein raumbildendes.
Flexibles, vollflächiges, raumbildendes Packmittel.
Ja genau.
Das ist definitiv.
Ändernbar.
Aus Baumwolle. Exactly.
Wir klammern im Volksmund Juteboy.
Können wir da nochmal schnell umbenennen?
Klar.
Ja dann machen wir das nochmal.
Ich bin schon unterwegs. Okay. Bis dahin entlassen wir euch den Rest der Woche
und sagen tschüss, bis bald.
Ciao ciao.
Ja, meine lieben, sehr geehrten Damen und Herren, Tata ist nun mal...
Die wirklich komischen Dinge kann man sich nun mal nicht ausdenken,
sondern die schreibt das Leben. Ich habe hier einen Text.
Es geht um Folgendes, ich meine, der ein oder andere wird schon mal ein Gerät
elektronischer, japanischer Unterhaltungstechnik gekauft haben.
Und beim Installationsversuch sowohl alte Männerfreundschaften wie die Ehe aufs
Spiel gesetzt haben und dann...
Die Gebrauchsanweisung zur Hand genommen und fortan nur noch Kofferradio von
Universum gehört haben.
Das geht nämlich nicht. Und zum Thema Gebrauchsanweisung die folgende.
Eine Dienstanweisung der Deutschen Bundespost.
Die klingt so.
In Dienstanfängerkreisen kommen immer wieder Verwechslungen der Begriffe Wert
Sack, Wert Beutel, Versackbeutel und Wert Paketsack vor.
Um diesem Übel abzuhelfen, ist das folgende Merkblatt dem Paragraf 49 der ADA vorzuheften.
Heften. Der Wert Sack ist ein Beutel,
der aufgrund seiner besonderen Verwendung im Postbeförderungsdienst nicht Wert Beutel,
sondern Wert Sack genannt wird, weil sein Inhalt aus mehreren Wertbeuteln besteht,
die in den Wert Sack nicht verbeutelt, sondern versackt werden.
Das ändert aber nichts an der Tatsache, dass die zur Bezeichnung des Wertes
Sacks verwendete Wert Beutelfahne auch bei einem Wert Sack mit Wert Beutelfahne
bezeichnet wird und nicht mit Wert Sack, Wert Sackbeutel oder Wert Beutelsackfahne.
Kleine Steigerung jetzt.
Sollte es sich bei der Inhaltsfeststellung eines Wertsackes herausstellen,
dass ein in einen Wertsack versackter Versackbeutel statt im Wertsack in einem
der im Wertsack versackten Wertbeutel hätte versackt werden müssen,
so ist die infrage kommende Versackstelle unverzüglich zu benachrichtigen.
Jetzt ein ganz zentraler Satz für den maskulinen Teil des Publikums.
Nach seiner Entleerung wird der Wert Sack wieder zu einem Beutel.
Und er ist doch bei der Beutelzählung nicht als Sack, sondern als Beutel zu zählen.
Bei einem im Ladezettel mit dem Vermerk Wert Sack eingetragenen Beutel handelt
es sich jedoch nicht um einen Wert Sack, haha, das wäre auch zu einfach,
sondern um einen Wert Paketsack.
Weil ein Wert Sack im Ladezettel nicht als solcher bezeichnet wird,
sondern lediglich durch den Vermerk versackt darauf hingewiesen wird,
dass sich bei dem versackten Wert Beutel um einen Wert Sack und nicht um einen
ausdrücklich mit Wert Sack bezeichneten Wert Paketsack handelt.
Ich finde das ist transparent und luzid bis hierhin.
Jetzt kommt die Katarsis, die Krönung, das Allerschönste überhaupt.
Die Klimax möchte ich beinahe meinen, da läuft es einem feucht die Beine runter.
Da heißt es nämlich, also Beutel abwärts quasi, da heißt es,
Verwechslungen sind insofern im Übrigen ausgeschlossen.
Als jeder Postangehörige weiß, dass ein mit Wert Sack bezeichneter Beutel kein
Wert Sack, sondern ein Wert Paketsack ist.
Herzlichen Dank. Vielen Dank.